Julie Stout: Okay, we are recording.
Julie Stout: Hello again, my name is Julie Stout. We are here for part 3 of the interviews with Richard Verdutis. I am located in Bloomington, Indiana, and Richard is located in Alexandria, Virginia, correct?
Richard Vidutis: Alexandria, that's right.
Julie Stout: Awesome. It is March 23rd, 2026, and we are going to dive into the questions focused on Richard Dawson himself, if you are ready.
Richard Vidutis: Sure.
Julie Stout: Awesome.
Julie Stout: So, my first question for you is related to your first encounter with Dawson. When and how did you first meet him, and what were your earliest impressions?
Richard Vidutis: I don't really remember when I first met her, and I was trying to remember
Richard Vidutis: how I got pulled into the project, maybe as soon as they learned that I was from Gary.
Richard Vidutis: I'm sure they tried to get me in there, and I… I did.
Richard Vidutis: I'm not sure when I first met him.
Richard Vidutis: I think it was during that one class that I took with him.
Richard Vidutis: Before that, I don't… I don't remember reading it.
Julie Stout: What was the class you took with him? Was it a history of folklore class?
Richard Vidutis: I wish I could remember, I… I don't remember. Not sure.
Richard Vidutis: It's too long ago.
Julie Stout: You mentioned… oh, sorry.
Richard Vidutis: Look up my transcripts and stuff.
Julie Stout: That's okay. You mentioned that your first impression, or one of your impressions of him was when he had the red marker out ready to, like, edit your writing, basically.
Julie Stout: What was your other first impression of him in general, if you can remember?
Richard Vidutis: Are you strict.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know if…
Richard Vidutis: I guess everybody has a sense of humor. I don't know what his or was exactly.
Richard Vidutis: he was always, I think… I think it was really important for him to publish, you know, that… that academic thing, publish a Paris thing, but he…
Richard Vidutis: He really did put out a lot of stuff.
Richard Vidutis: 20 books, and I don't know how many articles. So, it was a… I think that was on his mind all the time.
Richard Vidutis: You took a year off, and you went to… North Carolina?
Richard Vidutis: work on the manuscript, I think.
Richard Vidutis: So we put a lot of time into it.
Richard Vidutis: A lot of organization.
Julie Stout: What was the nature of your relationship? And in what ways did you work with him, and did that relationship change over time?
Richard Vidutis: I mean, just, the project, we would… He would
Richard Vidutis: follow us, or we followed him.
Richard Vidutis: To go someplace in Gary, northwest Indiana.
Richard Vidutis: That was about it.
Richard Vidutis: I think the other ones, like March and Buddunas, who started early, They probably consulted with him.
Richard Vidutis: Like I said, I came in late… And apparently there wasn't really… Any need for another…
Richard Vidutis: Interviewer, I guess, I don't know.
Richard Vidutis: Whatever.
Julie Stout: And he was your teacher first, and then kind of turned into your supervisor for the project, essentially?
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I'm trying to think, too, how did that work? Did I… I was taking classes, obviously, but did we, like, take time off to go to Gary? We must have.
Richard Vidutis: How often did we do that?
Richard Vidutis: Can't remember. I stayed with my parents all that time, of course.
Richard Vidutis: So, geez, I don't remember.
Julie Stout: Wasn't the project, I think, 6 weeks during the summer, I thought? Or…
Richard Vidutis: I know it was warm weather, so it… God, maybe it was in the summer?
Julie Stout: Oh, okay.
Julie Stout: I could be misremembering as well, but that is okay.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah.
Richard Vidutis: Everybody was outside doing stuff.
Julie Stout: So, you touched on this one a little bit, but I'd love to get more of your perspective on it, regarding his working style and expectations. You mentioned that he's very… he can be very strict.
Julie Stout: How would you describe Dawson's approach to research, supervision, and collaboration?
Richard Vidutis: I think he really set strict goals. He kept tabs on people that, were transcribing, and…
Richard Vidutis: On the field workers, what they were doing, where they were going.
Richard Vidutis: I guess there was… even though they had a lot of money, still.
Richard Vidutis: There was budget concerns, time concerns, So, he kept…
Richard Vidutis: He kept on top of all of that, it was demanding.
Richard Vidutis: It's smile, but you know that It was tough.
Richard Vidutis: So… Either played with him, or you stayed away from him, it's just… Wait, bro.
Julie Stout: What traits best capture Dawson as a person?
Julie Stout: Whether that be his communication style, temperament, you mentioned his humor and his smile, and how do these qualities show up in the day-to-day?
Richard Vidutis: He ran a tough ship, stripped ship to faculty, and departments.
Richard Vidutis: Everybody knew that, and they were careful not to get him upset, so… That's how he was,
Richard Vidutis: I don't think you produced 20 books in, I don't know, 100 articles or whatever it was, with
Richard Vidutis: By not being really strict and demanding.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, that really was his style.
Richard Vidutis: I came across a photo
Richard Vidutis: And I misplaced it again. I took in the… in the office.
Richard Vidutis: everybody was there. I don't know if, like, every student or something, he's there, and he's…
Richard Vidutis: And everybody's like, shh.
Richard Vidutis: Like, a bunch of soldiers are standing there strictly, and he's… they've got that smile, and then he's…
Richard Vidutis: Lecturing to everybody.
Richard Vidutis: And it's interesting, because… No one's laid back in this photo, they're all sort of…
Richard Vidutis: Carefully listening to him, not missing anything. They didn't want to upset him.
Richard Vidutis: So, yeah.
Julie Stout: I think that's a great, like, overview of seeing his interactions with other people, and also representing his personality at the same time. Would you agree?
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: For… regarding his decision-making and collaboration, this is mostly in relation to you and the Gary project, although if you have any other interaction with him regarding collaborating, let me know.
Julie Stout: Can you describe a situation where you or others collaborated with Dorsen, and how was it handled, and what did you take from the experience?
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I was never in that position to do that, you know?
Julie Stout: I think of.
Richard Vidutis: The other one's, like,
Richard Vidutis: Seward and Cooley and Benadunas in March, they obviously had to meet with Dawson and talk about what
Richard Vidutis: they were doing, but I just kind of tagged along all the time.
Richard Vidutis: Oh, because of that, when the next project came up, the Hungarian one.
Richard Vidutis: I was put in charge of the field work, logistics and stuff like that.
Richard Vidutis: That's basically what I did.
Julie Stout: Do you have anything else you want to add about the Hungarian project? In relation to my question?
Richard Vidutis: Oh, man.
Richard Vidutis: Not really, I just kind of wish that…
Richard Vidutis: Others across the country would have followed that as an example.
Richard Vidutis: Boom.
Richard Vidutis: For some reason, universities don't… Folklore faculties don't seem to do team kind of,
Richard Vidutis: investigations into communities. It's usually just individuals
Richard Vidutis: that's one of the reasons why I really enjoy working for FEMA, or when I worked,
Richard Vidutis: for CRM, Cultural Resource Management.
Richard Vidutis: They're all always teams. They're always working with.
Richard Vidutis: Historians, archaeologists, and we're the guy there who's hopefully an ethnographer.
Richard Vidutis: We need.
Richard Vidutis: Wish that was… Taken as an example, but it wasn't.
Richard Vidutis: I did learn years later, that some university in Chicago
Richard Vidutis: went to Northwest Indiana and did some kind of a survey.
Richard Vidutis: I always wondered what the heck that was. Was it cultural, or what?
Richard Vidutis: I have no idea what… University of Oklas.
Julie Stout: You mentioned you learned a lot about teamwork and the benefits of this project being done by a team instead of an individual.
Julie Stout: What was your impression of Dawson working within this team? I know he was a team leader, per se, but…
Julie Stout: Yeah, what is your impression of him in the group as a whole?
Richard Vidutis: Well, when he was in the field, he would actually
Richard Vidutis: you know, controlled what we were doing. He wanted to know When and where.
Richard Vidutis: What was happening.
Richard Vidutis: So, he was in control when he was there. There were times, probably, when he was back in Bloomington.
Richard Vidutis: Or he was also teaching at Northwest Indiana University.
Richard Vidutis: So, he wasn't with us all the time, but
Richard Vidutis: He kept a strict… a strict leash on everybody.
Richard Vidutis: I thought.
Richard Vidutis: Sent to me that way.
Julie Stout: Do you feel like you benefited from his guidance in particular? Do you think his, like, feedback and…
Julie Stout: Notes on your work, or other students' work, was helpful?
Richard Vidutis: Him particularly, I can't think of anything special that he did.
Richard Vidutis: he was, I don't think he was, he was focused on folklore.
Richard Vidutis: stories… expressive… Events… But somehow, it was just that. I mean, we're not…
Richard Vidutis: through the years, the stuff I've been doing is just very different. Still field work, still with people.
Richard Vidutis: You have to really scrounge deep, looking for stuff.
Richard Vidutis: He just kind of went in there with this mindset that he's gonna either find those stories or not.
Richard Vidutis: That's why it's, labeled, is there a folk in the City? which is ridiculous. Of course there is.
Richard Vidutis: He was just looking for those things, and he found what he was looking for.
Richard Vidutis: But… That's it, then… That's not negative.
Richard Vidutis: he, I think it was a really good folklore project when he carried that out.
Richard Vidutis: carry it off. And,
Richard Vidutis: beyond that, I don't know what to say. I mean, it wasn't anthropology, it wasn't anything else, it wasn't sociology.
Richard Vidutis: So he did what he was after, and then he did,
Richard Vidutis: With the, loggers, or they have with,
Richard Vidutis: What did he do up in Michigan and in Maine? It was the same thing, more or less.
Richard Vidutis: Just looking for the same stuff.
Julie Stout: I want to next touch on the stories that reveal his character. I know you mentioned a few already, but are there any other specific anecdotes you can think of that illustrate what he was like to work with?
Richard Vidutis: Just, again, when we were with them, we were careful to… do it correctly.
Richard Vidutis: There was one little funny anecdote. It was at, I think a Croatian, maybe a Serbian.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know what it was, some kind of a gathering, a lot of music and a lot of dancing, and he picked up the video.
Richard Vidutis: And, he stuck the lens in his eye.
Richard Vidutis: Like, if you take a camera and you stick the lens in your eye trying to take a picture of this. And I think he's on film somewhere doing that, something like that.
Richard Vidutis: It just shows he had absolutely no technical understanding other than maybe the, you know, a cassette toy.
Julie Stout: It must have been pretty interesting to see him in that context as well. Someone who's, like, a respected scholar, strict, as maybe you would say, and then he was kind of struggling with the technical aspects a bit.
Richard Vidutis: Yep.
Julie Stout: So my… oh, sorry.
Richard Vidutis: I just want to add that I don't think he was very comfortable with with ethnics who…
Richard Vidutis: Didn't speak English.
Richard Vidutis: A lot of those didn't carry, you know? Like I said, I grew up speaking just Lithuanian with my parents.
Richard Vidutis: A lot of people like that, like, I…
Richard Vidutis: All my friends had either parents or grandparents who spoke the language.
Richard Vidutis: And, that was the male language in many cases, it wasn't English.
Richard Vidutis: So, I don't know how he felt about that. I mean…
Richard Vidutis: That's why there isn't all that much. He writes about ethics, he has a whole chapter on it, but…
Richard Vidutis: the language thing… He doesn't talk about that. Is there a folklore of steel? If there is.
Richard Vidutis: He says there is some kind, I'm not sure what…
Richard Vidutis: He's talking about, but there would have been…
Richard Vidutis: And each respective ethnic group and their language.
Richard Vidutis: That's for sure, and that's a whole different… Kettle of fish,
Richard Vidutis: That he didn't approach so well.
Richard Vidutis: Crystal.
Richard Vidutis: For whatever reason.
Julie Stout: I think… It's something interesting to think about, especially when you're going into
Julie Stout: The fact that most of his students did speak a second language.
Julie Stout: But he… did he not tell you to focus on people that spoke a different language and encourage you to speak that language with them? Or was it just capture these sorts of things?
Richard Vidutis: I don't think he was concerned about language at all. He was always looking for expressive culture.
Richard Vidutis: Wow.
Richard Vidutis: Musicians, dancing, stories… Behaviors, opinions about…
Richard Vidutis: Other people, that sort of stuff.
Richard Vidutis: Typical folkloric stuff.
Richard Vidutis: But… He's not… I don't think he spoke any other language, so…
Richard Vidutis: It's… it's very difficult for somebody to come into a community like that, and… Try to understand it.
Richard Vidutis: I mean, I've been up to Michigan, My fieldwork took…
Richard Vidutis: Me a total of 13 months.
Richard Vidutis: And I mean…
Richard Vidutis: I've hung out with all kinds of what I call fins. They're American fins, but they're fins.
Richard Vidutis: And, even to this day.
Richard Vidutis: I'm not accepted, totally. You know, it's just the way it works.
Richard Vidutis: And so there are things that I try to understand to find out.
Richard Vidutis: And it's… Not gonna happen, so…
Richard Vidutis: He should have leaned on, Atlanta in March.
Richard Vidutis: And maybe hired somebody who spoke another language to get into those communities.
Richard Vidutis: talk to them, interview them in their own languages. That would have been… wow, that would have been a totally different chapter.
Julie Stout: I think it's something, like, an interesting perspective of what future fieldwork could look like in this community, is bringing in the language aspect into the fieldwork itself.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Richard Vidutis: That would be really important.
Julie Stout: It would kind of fill a gap, per se, maybe.
Julie Stout: In this work.
Julie Stout: So my last question regarding Dawson is about legacy.
Julie Stout: How has your view of Dawson's contributions evolved over time, and what should students and future researchers understand about his impact and the complexities of his legacy?
Richard Vidutis: Well, I think it's pretty well known, you know, For his,
Richard Vidutis: Historical background, and he's been sort of dismissed by a lot of people.
Richard Vidutis: But I think here, he stepped into something a little bit different at a time when there was great interest in the country about ethnicity.
Richard Vidutis: And he should have talked about more about languages, but he didn't.
Richard Vidutis: But he was just part of that, I call it that great movement, the ethnic awakening. He wasn't the only scholar who wrote about ethnicity. There were, God, there was just endless numbers of books and dissertations that came out at that time.
Richard Vidutis: He was part of that.
Richard Vidutis: A lot of scholars do just,
Richard Vidutis: archival and the library kind of research, but he actually went out there
Richard Vidutis: In the community, that is feet 30.
Richard Vidutis: He sought out people.
Richard Vidutis: And that's hardcore fieldwork.
Richard Vidutis: So, I praise him for that.
Richard Vidutis: I mean, you could argue about theory and all that stuff, but
Richard Vidutis: He set up a really great example, and it said that it wasn't followed.
Richard Vidutis: In different ways, to meet different situations, different times.
Richard Vidutis: But he did it.
Richard Vidutis: Glory to Dorset.
Julie Stout: And on that note, is there anything else you'd like to add about Dawson himself, whether that be your experiences with him, comments, perspectives, anything else you'd like to add?
Richard Vidutis: Not much, not much, except that
Richard Vidutis: red pen came out, out of nowhere. Attacked my paper. No, I really don't know much more, except…
Richard Vidutis: There was no other… situation where I dealt with, like the Gary project, and that was…
Richard Vidutis: Not very extensive, actually, but… That was the only, really, the only time.
Julie Stout: Well, regardless, I appreciate your taking time to let me ask you these questions.
Julie Stout: And your contribution is still definitely noted within the project.
Julie Stout: And people like me still know that about your contribution to the project itself. So, yeah.
Julie Stout: That's good.
Richard Vidutis: Anything else in the future, let me know.
Julie Stout: I will. I'm gonna stop the recording here.
Richard Vidutis: Okay.